I
hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast spotlights on T cells new
developments for translational and basic
T cell research I'm Julie Clark and I'll
be your moderator for today's event we
are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots and sponsored by miltenyi the
miltenyi biotec mission is to improve
scientific understanding and medical
progress by providing products and
services that advanced biomedical
research and cellular therapy honoring
this mission drives our commitment to
support the translation of basic
research into therapy in the areas of
immunology cancer neuroscience and stem
cell biology for more information please
visit WWE biotech com we have a few
important announcements before we begin
this webcast is designed to be
interactive and we encourage you to ask
questions during the event you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window we'll
try to answer as many questions as we
can you can enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window if
you have any technical problems viewing
or hearing this presentation please
click on the support button at the top
right of your presentation window or
submit your problem through the green
Q&A button on the lower left I would now
like to introduce today's speaker dr.
Ann Richter dr. Richter studied biology
at the University of Cologne Germany she
obtained her PhD working on T helper
cell polarization at the german
rheumatism Research Center in 2000
afterwards she joined miltenyi biotec as
a project leader in rd regent reagent
department developing methods and
reagents for self declaration culturing
and analysis to date she heads the T
cell analogy in flow analysis group
focusing on the development of
innovative tools for research
applications in the field of adaptive
t-cell therapy I'll now turn it over to
dr. Richter hello and welcome to the
seminar today Thank You Jewry for the
introduction today I would like you to
guide you through several
topics the first is I'd like to give you
a short introduction into military
biotech then I will come to discuss with
you teaser workflows and the last point
I will focus on the flow cytometric
analysis for sensitive andreas 7 Alice's
so first of all some words to miltenyi
biotec we are accompanied with
subsidiaries in 25 countries and we have
distributions in another 34 countries
our headquarter is located in Germany
bergisch gladbach that's a small town
close to clone here or a research and
development of work as well as
production is done and especially the
manufacturing of our GMP and clinic a
great product that's performed at the
second side in Germany it's located in
east germany so our mission is to serve
the needs and life science research and
to translate new scientific findings
into clinical applications we are
actively developing reagents media
buffer instruments plus software for
applications in the field of sample
preparation magnetic cell isolation flow
cytometric analysis cell culture
designed for basic research purposes
important is to know that we build up
our clinical product portfolio with the
same technologies as we use them for our
research product defect extremely
simplifies the translation of
applications from research level into
clinical practice we are closely working
together with investigators in the early
phases of development of clinical
applications to ensure the most easiest
and fastest translational process in
many cases even the clinical
applications are the driver to choose
and implement technology into our
company which we then additionally
provide in our research portfolio later
on I will mention some examples so but
first I like to start with our max cell
separation technology and this is
business meeting
arted with more than 25 years ago and we
introduced the max microb technology
this technology uses nano sized
paramagnetic beads in combination with
columns and magnetic separators for
either positive enrichment of cells
depletion of unwanted cells or isolation
of untouched cells the system was
developed an able cell isolation without
affecting the cell besides we are often
a magnetic separation system max express
which consists of micro-sized beads and
a separator the system does not meet a
column and is especially useful for fast
depletion of unwanted cells for example
from whole blood but let's have a closer
look to the micro bead technology why do
we utilize a column in general the
magnetic separators in column based and
callum free system has a comparable
magnetic force the difference between
the system is the column so when the
column is placed into a mock separator
the gradient of the magnetic forces gets
amplified by ten thousand fold due to
the little iron fees that are packed in
the column thus a minimal labeling of
cells with tiny nano beads is a
sufficient to retain labored cells in
the column the ayran fears have cell
friendly coating moreover self can run
freely through the column and can be
washed truly to remove unlabeled cells
soda breeze or contaminants all this
contributes to the fact that max columns
allow for sale separation with minimal
effects on cells beside this max
separations cell separation systems are
very easy and handy as it will be shown
on the next slide so basically the
magnetic separation using the max microb
technology has three steps the first
step is the magnetic labeling of cells
in suspension the magnetic nano beads
are coated with antibodies which
recognize certain cell surface antigens
on cell and secondly then the cell
suspension with magnetically labeled
cells is put onto a column which is
fixed in a magnetic separator the
magnetic forces of the separator which
are amplified by other column will
retain now the labeled cells in the
column the unlabeled cells flow through
the column and can be collected as
depleted first fraction in a third step
the cells retained in the column can
simply be eluded from the column which
is then outside the magnet using your
stamp and this fraction is then the
magnetical labeled cells the positively
enriched tells the microb technology is
a gold standard in magnetic separation
it is used for basic research
applications in furthermore it's used
for various clinical application also
for positive enrichment of cells and
subsequent injection into patients so we
are offering a comprehensive portfolio
of micro bead based product for
separation of many cells but as shown on
this slide we have already a huge part
for you to separate mouse and human
cells panty sets as well as subsets of
t-cell like naive or memory T cells or t
regulatory cells or even cytokine
expressing concerns in the following I
like to share with you our work to
streamline research on pieces showing
two examples of workflows the first one
is the workflow for Mouse T helper cell
differentiation in vitro this slide
shows to you a simplified model of
differentiation of naive t helper cells
into cell subsets having various
different effector functions
differentiation of naive t helper cells
starts with its primary activation via
the t cell receptor in vivo the t cell
receptor recognized
kajen peptide antigens prevented on
image MHC class 2 molecules which are on
the cell surface of professional antigen
presenting cells like dendritic cells
but in addition to this first signal the
TCR triggering co-stimulatory signals
are required to ensure the full
activation of the pieces for example
cd28 on the t cell as a bit trigit
additional signals delivered by
cytokines during the primary activation
phase imprint a certain differentiation
program in the T helper cell for example
the presence of our 12 during the
activation instruct the T helper cell to
develop in a th1 cell Emmure of tgf-beta
r6 ultimately won an odd 23 will induce
the differentiation of th17 cells
whereas our four induces th2 cells so
when several more T helper cell subsets
are described such as th9 cells induced
regulatory T cells or tea for liquor
Lascelles the hallmark of each of the
t-cell subsets is a certain set of
expressed transcription factors which
direct the expression of a certain
effector cytokine pattern t help affair
1 cells are characterized by the
expression of the transcription factor
stat4 and T bet which are induced which
are inducing the expression of gamma
interferon and TNF alpha 17 cells are
marked by the presence of stat3 and Rho
gamma T which are required to induce of
17 and our 22 expression the high degree
of the different effective cytokines is
important to fight appropriately against
the different pathogens we are attacking
by or to maintain tolerance to which
harmless antigens and also inadequate
effector functions can result in
diseases and this is a reason why
researchers are interested to understand
the differentiation process and to
analyze T helper cell effect repentance
the pio cell differentiation process can
be mimicked in vivo and
most easiest with mouths t-helper cells
so for this approach several steps are
required first Mouse limb freed itself
need to be prepared for example from
spleen or from lymph nodes then the
naive t helper cells have to be selected
and in vitro cultured reagent for
activation of the t cell receptor
include the military molecules are
provided as well as cytokines to induce
the differentiation pathway as well as
culture subculture media is needed so in
to prove the differentiation the
analysis of for example transcription
factors is done or affected side
accounts so coming to the separation of
naive t cells so now if key sets are
characterized by the expression of cd62l
and the absent of the memory marker cd44
based on this marker we provide magnetic
separation kits to isolate these cells
for example as shown in this slide we
isolate naive t cells using the naive
cd4 t-cell isolation kit this micro bead
based kit depletes all non cd4 t-cells
and additionally cd25 positive t-rex and
effector cells as well as cd44 memory
cells from the lymphoid cells suspension
on the left hand side a flow cytometric
analysis of sets before the magnetic
depletion is shown and in the middle and
on the right side the pleated cell
fraction so as depicted in the upper row
you see the purity of the enriched c4
positive T cells and in the middle you
see the purity of the naive kisses
isolated and you can easily see that
there are cd44 negative cd62l positive
cells are enriched to a purity of more
than 96 and 97 percent in this example
we show a menu enrichment of the naive t
cells as well as an automated
enrichment using the autumn xpro
instrument and the lower row shows you
that also the t-rex and effector cells
are gone using this depletion kit of
course we were interested to look if the
depletion really resides in my eve
kisses and one of the characteristics of
naive kisses is that they do not express
sector cytokines and therefore we did a
short-term stimulation of either the
unselected spleen cells or selected
naive t cells with PM areola myosin and
afterwards we did an interest al-assad
Oh containing for gamma interfere and as
you can easily see relatives in the
spleen cells can interfere in producing
cells are detectable within the naive
teasing compartment no gamma interferon
producing cell is detect it is depicted
having now isolated the naive t cells
these T cells need to be cultured for in
vitro teaser differentiation several
reagents are required cell culture media
activation reagent cytokines to induce
the effector cytokine expression and if
their culture is very complex because
many regions are provided to the cells
which have an effect on these cells
either wanted effects but also undesired
effect can be caused by undefined
components and ingredients especially
driven by our clinical applications we
were interested to develop reagents and
media which are defined first of all
from regulatory perspective clinical
grade products require to be defined
standardized and defined in standardized
reagent a key element to enable
reproducibility in your application but
that's too not only for clinical
application but it's also a huge
advantage for research application so
for this differentiation process you
will need cell culture media so and for
this purpose we developed special media
to culture tea set the tex-mex medium
for T cell activation you have several
possibilities either you can pull only
stimulate cell
using soluble on plate bound antibodies
recognizing and binding to city three
and cd28 we developed artificial antigen
presenting cells these are based on big
beads the maxi beads and these maxi
beads are coded with a ballistic
antibodies towards c3 and cd28 for
antigen specific activation we use pools
of peptides which cover the complete
protein sequence of an antigen and this
foods allow the activation of c-4 as
well as cd8 positive self so to induce
the differentiation of certain subsets
of effector T helper cells inducing
cytokines is needed and for this purpose
we developed recombinant cytokines and
these are animal and human derived
component free cytokines to avoid
undefined side effects which is
important for clinical but also for
research application and last but not
least we are using for our
differentiation process also antibodies
to neutralize inducing cytokines to
inhibit the wrong differentiation
program and just mention what we what we
attested when we developed our max tex
mex medium this medium is not only used
for polyclonal activation of panty sets
but also used for antigen specific
t-cell activation also regulatory t-cell
expansion is done with this medium and
we use it also for multi helper cell
differentiation beside the medium you
need for your differentiation program
t-cell activation reagents so in this
slide I'd like to show you an example
where we use the artificial intervene
presenting cells meaning the maxi beats
loaded with cd3 and c28 antibody for the
activation of mouse T cells for this
experiment we labeled spleen cells with
CFS II to follow their proliferation and
activate them with the artificial
antigen presenting
and as you can see already on day one
you see a nice expression of the
activation market cd25 which is
upregulated in the city for compartment
and on day 2 and day for you clearly can
see that the CFS a delusion decline CFS
enabling declines meaning that the cells
are proliferating and when we determine
the expansion rate after eight days we
found out that cd4 as well as cd8
t-cells proliferated by up to 100-fold
we use the artificial intervals in the
artificial apc's not only for expansion
of mouse psets but it's also used for
human t-cell activation expansion for
human tirak expansion and even we are
this designed t-rex oppression essay
using this the maxi beads so beside the
cell culture medium and the activation
reagents you need cytokines to induce
the differentiation pathway we bundled
the required cytokines as well as the
blocking antibodies into a kid that we
call Saito box this slide shows the
result of a five-day differentiation of
max isolated naive cd4 t-cells which are
stimulated with CD 3 328 maxi beads in
the tex-mex medium and in addition with
either reagents to induce th1
differentiation th2 differentiation or
th 70 different stations we prove that
the differentiation works by staining
the cells for mass transcription factors
and as you can see on the left hand side
th one cell cultures in these couches
ninety-nine percent of all cells are
positive 40-bit within the th2 culture
99% of the cells express gata3 but not
directly expressed and most of the cells
within the th1 th 17 culture express the
keymaster transcription factor Rho gamma
Chi
beside the analysis of Mark a master
transcription factors I showed you
before we also analyzed cells for the
relevant effector cytokine expression
and after reactivation with premium ifen
on day four of these differentiation
cultures we detected in th th oneself as
a pet as expected gamma interview but no
al for expression in cage to culture
I'll for but not comment a few
production was detectable and then th17
culture of seventeen producing cells but
not gum interfere an expression was
detectable interestingly we observe when
we compared the culture medium rpm I and
tex-mex that the level of the cytokine
expression was much higher when we use
the tex-mex medium all in all these
means that we have established with all
reagents for separation by culturing and
cell analysis or workflow for the in
vitro differentiation of mouth t-helper
cells but what's about to identify and
characterize vivo differentiated T
helper cells for this purpose we
establish the cytokine secretion as a
technology this technology is unique and
allow the detection as well as the
isolation of viable cytochem producing
cells the principle of the cytokine
secretion technology is as follow after
T cell stimulation sets are labeled with
the catch matrix this catch matrix
consists of two antibodies conjugated to
each other one antibody recognized cd45
antigen on all leukocytes and the second
antibody is specific for a cytokine for
example I 17 the catch reagent is
anchored to the cell surface whyever
cd45 antibody when cells secrete the
cytokine this cytokine is catched by the
catch matrix on the secreting sell the
cytokine producing cell can afterwards
be fluorescently labeled with second
anti second antibody which allows flow
analysis
or even flow 40 alternatively the
cytokine secreting cells kahneman we can
be magnetically isolated after
indigenous microbeads labeling step this
technique is able is available for many
cytokines and one example I like to
share with you is the detection and the
Magnetic isolation of our 17 secreting
cells from mouse princess we detected in
the simulated sample oh point three six
percent of our 70 producing cells among
the cd4 positive T cell population and
after the magnetic enrichment we
achieved the purity of sixty percent
besides three forces also other selves
in mouth clean cells are able to produce
aisle 17 and they are even also enriched
the same technology allows also the
isolation of gamma interferon secreting
cells for manufacturing of clinical
grade virus-specific pieces this
procedure run in a fully automated way
using a cell processor the clinic max
prodigy instruments which is shown here
in the picture to summarize this part of
the presentation so we established a
whole workflow for in vitro
differentiation of 34 t cells starting
with the magnetic isolation of naive
cells proceeding with the cell culturing
and finishing with analysis of the
differentiated cultures in the next
slide I like to discuss a workflow for
research with human regulatory t-cells
human t-rex are mostly isolated from
blood products like pmc or her blood
they are enriched according to the
phenotypic cell surface markers city for
c 25 and see 127 t-rex are expanded and
are characterized afterwards including
the detection of for example 43 the key
transcription factor or other scientific
markers are analyzed or even the t-rex
are functionally analyzed you
depression is a to allow a very fast
enrichment of human t-rex directly from
whole blood within just 30 minutes we
combine both of our mock separation
technologies the max express and the
micro b technology the protocol starts
with incubation of whole blood cells
with a cocktail of magnetic max express
beads to label non target cells but also
of cd25 positive cells with max
microbeads after in short incubation
step the sample is placed into a max
express separator to delete unwanted
cells and replica red blood cells the
supernatant is collected and directly
transferred onto a column which is
placed into a max microbead magnet cd25
positive cells unreached in the column
unwanted cells flow through the target
cells namely the cd4 positive cd25
positive city 127 low cells are then
eluded from the column what is the
result of this enrichment with flow
cytometric analysis we determine the
purity and the yield of the isolated
t-rex overall we achieved a ninety
percent purity of City for 325 positive
cells and seventy-five percent purity of
cd4 325 positive city 127 low cells
importantly the number of isolated t-rex
is 2.5 fold higher compared to an
isolation strategy which fruit needs the
separation of pbmc wire identity
gradient centrifugation step this
isolated cells can also be expanded
using the artificial a pcs which
specifically were developed for
expanding of regulatory t-cells here an
example is shown where we use also the
tex-mex medium our two and rapamycin and
we detected within that deserves expand
by a factor of 40 Ford within three
weeks the week
via Fox p3 so the key transcription
factor which specific forty wreck
remains stable expressed during the
whole culture in this example around
seventy percent in summary I presented
to your workflow for research on
regulatory t set isolated directly from
whole blood using to Mac separation
technologies during the expansion of
these cells with our activation tools
cytokines and tex-mex medium and doing
flow analysis to to phenotype the t-rex
we also established a t-rex depression a
set to test the functional capacity of
the t-rex but i have no slides today for
this and what is also important is that
we beside a portfolio of reagent and
technology that we established for
research application with t rex we
provide also hall workflows for GMP
manufacturing of t-rex including the
magnetic enrichment of sense expanding
of these as well as the quality control
where we assess the phenotypical and
functional properties of the cellular
products the last topic I'll I to
address is the flow cytometric analysis
of rare cell populations what is
important to allow sensitive and rare
cell detection by flow cytometry for
example the ex vivo detection of
antigen-specific t cells one thing which
is very important is that the flow
cytometer have to have a very low
carryover of self secondly the number of
secondly the number of cells that has to
be acquired have sufficient high enough
to be able to detect their survey
ourselves but even the analysis of large
samples on the flow cytometer has its
limit because low-frequency operations
cannot be discriminated from other
non-target
us as the large number of non-target
cell signal overlays with a signal of
the target population here the magnetic
pre enrichment of target cells prior to
the flow analysis is a solution
furthermore a bright painting of the
target cell population is necessary and
specifically labeling of the target
cells is also required I like to address
three of these points in more detail the
pre enrichment the bride staining and
the specific labeling and I will stand
with a topic of enriched magnetic pre
enrichment to allow a very high solution
characterization of rare cd4-positive
antigen-specific t cells we developed a
method we named rapid antigens reactive
t-cell enrichment rapid artists and this
method allows the characterization of
records within one day and its really a
fast alternative to long-term culture
with repetitive antigenic simulations to
allow for detection a characterization
of rare antigen-specific t cells so the
protocols starts with a short term
entered the next simulation of pbmc for
several hours for example three to six
hours with an antigenic peptide after
this period within the psychology dishes
we add antibodies for cell surface
markers like cd4 + CD three or even four
characterization of memory and naive
cells and we are doing as well magnetic
labeling of the antigen activated T
cells using the activation marker cd154
so we do a direct labeling of cd154 with
memory with microbeads and directly
after this labeling step cells are fixed
all these steps are done without any
washing of centrifugation step in the
culture dish after having fix the cells
these are loaded onto the column the
target cells meaning the
created cd154 positive pieces are
retained on the column why are the
magnetic labeling to analyze now the
cytokine repertoire within these antigen
activated cd4 positive T cells an
intracellular cytokine Stanley is
performed on the column and after
illusion of the target cells from the
column the flow cytometric analysis can
be done on the Mexican instrument and
that run automatically so this analysis
can be performed overnight the whole
enrichment and laboring procedure takes
in total just one hour no centrifugation
is required and when we calculate
additional six our simulation period
it's clear that this protocol can easily
be performed within a working day we use
this method to characterize for example
the repertoire of fungus specific tea
sets in this example shown here we
stimulated to be MC from a healthy donor
with after july eight for seven hours
afterwards the espadrille specific City
one had 64 positive self-serving
ethically enriched and interest and less
paint for various cytokines in healthy
individuals normally around Oh point one
to send of the city 40s a repertoire
reacts towards a bajillion using now the
magnetic separation of sea 150 for
positive itself we enrich the epidural
specific chainset here to around thirty
percent where we now screen for the
effective cytokine repertoire within
this population we clearly detect gamma
Trivium producing cells in this example
4.2 percent and only open six percent
ten producing sense in comparison with
all the enrichment before the flow
cytometric analysis we detected Oh point
oh five percent of gum interfere in
producing such so the gamma interferon
producing cells were overestimated
whereas our ten producing cells could
not be detected because of the low
frequency
by this method now some small population
women within a complete T cell
repertoire of aspergillus and camilla
specific tea sets were identified and
you can clearly see here the differences
in the cytokine repertoire between key
set specific for one or the other of
these fungus for example of 17 and I 22
producing cells a much higher in
frequency within the Canada specific
rabeteh compared to the original
specific repeater these differences
would not be uncovered without this
method and next I like to discuss the
importance of a specific labeling you
may have noticed the publication by
Andrew babirye and andreas platoon about
the need to standardize antibody
reagents for research purposes for
example by using recombinantly
engineered antibodies already before
this comment came out we implemented the
manufacturing of recombinant engineered
antibodies into our company our RIA
finity technology select the best clones
with the highest specificity and
affinity they are envy need not to bind
to FC receptors for example they for
example FC are blocking is not required
to inhibit background staining of false
positives event they are optimized in
sequence that means we eliminated
unwanted conjugation signs within the
variable regions which result then in a
lot of antigen binding and all our RIA
antibodies are human igg isotype and
kappa light chain so that means that
only one isotope control antibody is
required for the analysis in some this
means that recombinant engineered
antibodies allow a standardized
manufacturing process which results also
an optimal performance of these reagents
last but not least the bride's training
is needed we are developing new
fluorescent dyes which
extend the brightness of the
conventional diet for example the nude
iyo brad pitt's conjugated to cd4 cd8
antibodies resides and higher mean for
sp2 intensity than a simple fit
conjugate but it is as bright as a PE
conjugate brightness matters in relative
parameter analysis with dimly expressed
markers for example cd25 to identify
t-rex with new brighter dies the
flexibility for selection of antibody
reagents much higher and in this example
the characterization of human t-rex was
shown which were isolated from pbmc and
on the left hand side you see the gating
of viral cd4 positive ki said they were
identified by excluding viability formed
for 420 fixable die and we use CD for a
PC vaio 770 to identify the three four
cells then T cells were also stained for
four cd25 while bride fits and we
exclude see 127 positive cells the t-rex
was furthermore characterized and
subdivided in memory and naive
population using cd45ro very blue and
cd45 PE by 0615 conjugates and for both
of these compartments we then looked for
Fox p3 expression and we looked for
proliferating and recently activated
cells using the internal clear marker
ki67 so the combination of new bride via
does with the rear finiti antibody
creates very new standards and multi
parameter flow and then panels to sum up
my talk for our t-cell workflows we have
established optimized tools for sampled
Association sample separate cell
separation by culturing
balance of cell analysis and we are not
only providing this tool for research
purposes but we are also setting up this
tool for clinical application with this
I like to thank you for your attention
and I hope for a very fruitful
discussion thank you it lands with an
informative presentation before we get
started on the question and answer
session I'd like to remind our audience
how to submit questions you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green and Q&A button at the lower left
of the presentation window will try to
answer as many questions as you can all
right um so our first question is did
you ever test the functionality of your
isolated boxes we can write down yes
that's a very good question as I
mentioned we have developed extra
reagents to identify up a suppression
essay and this essay uses also the maxi
beads coated with cd3 and 328 antibodies
and we nice you can see that the t-rex
we are isolating are suppressing we
usually use a flow cytometric essay
where we labeled the responder self with
with a dye and we looked at the delusion
of this dye to define the suppressive
activity and for all our separation
reagents we did this and this clearly
shows that that the tease t-rex are
functional after the magnetic isolation
as well as after the expanded face thank
you Anna we have another question we
always use plate bound antibodies for
t-cell activation do your act your
activation be stimulate more efficiently
and do I need to remove them afterwards
so yeah we
had a lot of house experience with plate
bound antibodies for t-cell activation
and our experience bought that there
were not really reliable protocols
available and we had problems to
reproduce our results and with our my
maxi beads we were able to standardize
the activation of the cells so and in
general these beads have not to be
removed from the culture during the
expansion phase thinking and the next
question is what temperature do you
store your sample reagents so when the
reagents are delivered to the customer
there most of the reagents are stored
within the fridge and if this is not the
case then we mark it on our region how
to store the reagent thank you and the
next question is do you have a
comparison between using cd3 cd28 based
activation t cells versus max I beads
yeah as I mentioned before we did this
in house and we had problems to
reproduce the results with 33 32 28 and
therefore we use the max if it the next
question is is a tex-mex media are ready
to use medium for T cells or do I need
to add supplements yes that's an
important question because normally you
add for the media serum and serum is a
very variable component and this medium
works without any additional supplements
so you can use just these mediums for
cultivation of your t cells thank you
will the slides be available online
yes there will be online available all
right after stimulation with Maxie beads
do you need to remove beads prior to
analysis by flow cytometry so the big
beads so after expanding off the t cells
the beads are not any longer sticking to
the cells so they can be discriminated
from the cells thank you let's see can
you give us directly into sight for
reagents and what is the average cost
for the media with supplements I'm sorry
Judy can you repeat it please the
question yes and this individual would
like I guess more information as to how
to find the the reagents directly and I
believe that we will be providing
information on the new candy biotech
link archived with this presentation so
I think you filled in find information
for all reagents on our website Thank
You Anne the next question is you die
you used did not increase the number of
cells only increase mfi did you use
these diets on any low mfi antigens yet
that's also an important question I shot
you an example with a vaio bride fit for
c4 and cd8 t-cells and these markers are
highly expressed and normally you do not
have problems to detect them but I
showed one example where we use the
virus it's to identify t-rex cells and
also there we
achieve the same mean fluorescence
intensity than with a PE conjugate so
that means that you have now more
options also to stay in these dim Marcus
like cd24 and cd25 with other markers
and you have the PE and the apt Chandler
free for other limb markers Thank You en
after isolation do you see death of some
of the t-rex if so what percentage of
t-rex died before they start expanding
so we are looking carefully to our
culture and we normally do not detect
dying t-rex alright how do you compare
the permanent [ __ ] stain on columns with
the conventional term fix method so this
is can easily be done because you can
after separation of the magnetically
labeled cells elude the cells and do the
staining then either in suspension all
you leave the enriched cells on the
column and perform then the
intracellular painting and afterwards
you can go to the flow cytometer and
compare the performance of both of these
protocols and it will result in the same
thank you in did you ever test the
functionality of your isolated Fox p3
positive ki reg cells yeah I think we
have the question be before but I so yes
we normally test the functionality of
our t-rex after the isolation and also
after the expansion and for this we
designed an extra sa a function and sa
the tee RAK suppression inspector and
this allows you to test the
functionality of the two of the t-rex
cells you have maxi maxi beads
pressing only cd3 and only cd28
antibodies I need to compare
stimulations by each antibody
individually yeah so we have predefined
kids where CDC and cd28 is already
provided in the kit but we are but we
also provide anti biotene maxi beads and
you can have also c3 and cd28 biotin
antibody separately 22 to use this in a
flexible way and to design your
artificial apcs as you want you can even
use further antibiotic antibodies and
load these maxi beads to test the
influence all right um if there are no
more answer I mean no more questions I'd
like to thank and Victor for her
presentation and you have any final
comments so I'd like to thank you all to
the audience and yeah peace please feel
free if you have further questions to
contact one of US military either go
wild tech support so we will be happy to
take your questions and to help you
Thank You Ann for your presentation
again and thank you miltenyi biotec for
making today's webcast possible today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through december twenty three
twenty sixteen you will receive an email
from lab roots alerting when this
webcast will be available for replay we
invite you to for that announcement to
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event see you next time
goodbye